>> Good Morning, YouTubers. My name is John
Holmes and I'm responsible for coordinating
disaster relief in the world dealing with
the poorest and those suffering the most in
the world. My plea to people in countries
or companies or individuals, in particular
those who are here at Davos at the moment,
is when they are talking about the financial
crisis or the big political crises of the
world, to give a bit more thought to the effect
on the ground, in the real world, particularly
on the poorest in the world. Only a small
proportion on the resources that go into financial
issues, whether they've been lost or won,
the many billions we're talking about, only
a small proportion of those resources given
to those poorest in the world would make the
difference. Only a small proportion of thought
going to the effect on those people, not just
the poorest but also in developing counties
in general, could make a huge difference so
let's make a bit more of a connection between
those debates and the realities on the ground
and we have a mechanism to do that. For example,
through the Central Emergency Response Fund,
which is a UN fund, to help disaster relief.
Any contributions are very welcome and gratefully
received.